AND THAT IS A STORY FOR US
TONIGHT, FRIDAY AUGUST
♪
>> WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
HAPPY FRIDAY, WHAT A WEEK IT WAS
BRAID THE PRESIDENT EXHIBITED
HIS PARTY’S NOMINATION LAST
NIGHT FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
HE GAVE A LONG SPEECH, MORE THAN
70 MINUTES COMPARE THAT TO JOE
BIDEN’S 24 MINUTE.
AND THE PRESIDENTS WASN’T
WRITTEN WITH SOUNDBITES FOR
TWITTER, IT WAS PRETTY MEDIUM.
HE SPOKE AT LENGTH ABOUT TRADE
IN MANUFACTURING, JOBS, HE
WARNED ABOUT ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION
AND THE BURDEN OF MORE REFUGEES
FROM DANGEROUS COUNTRIES PRAYED
HE POINTED TO JOE BIDEN’S RECORD
WHICH IS THIN, CORRUPT, AND A
LIFE OR A BRIGHT MAN WHO AFTER
50 YEARS CAN’T POINT TO A SINGLE
POLICY ACHIEVEMENT PRAYED THE
BEST PART OF THE SPEECH CAME
EARLY ON WHEN TRUMP WHICH YOU
ALREADY KNOW BEAR THIS IS NOT A
WICKED NATION.
ARE COPS AREN’T INHERENTLY
RACIST, NEITHER IS AMERICA.
THEY TELL YOU THAT CONSTANTLY,
BUT THEY ARE LYING.
THE UNITED STATES HAS FLAWS, BUT
IT’S ALSO THE PRESIDENT REMINDED
US LAST NIGHT THE MOST FREE,
JUST AND EXCEPTIONAL NATION ON
EARTH.
THAT’S TRUE.
IN OUR COUNTRY FREE SPEECH IS
ALLOWED, VIOLENCE IS NOT ALLOWED
PRAYED WHAT SEPARATES AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY FROM CALIBAN
BUREAUCRACY FOR EXAMPLE IS THAT
IN AMERICA PEOPLE CAN DISAGREE
WITH ONE ANOTHER AND DISAGREE
WITH THE GOVERNMENT WITHOUT
FEARING FOR THEIR LIVES.
THIS USED TO BE OBVIOUS.
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN JOE BIDEN
COULD NEVER SAY THIS OUT LOUD.
HIS VOTERS HAVE DESTROYED CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND MURDERED
DOZENS OF AMERICANS.
DONALD TRUMP DOESN’T HAVE TO, SO
HE SAID IT AND AS A RESULT, FOR
THE FIRST TIME SINCE THE
CORONAVIRUS ARRIVED HERE, THE
PRESIDENT SEEMED LIKELY TO WIN
REELECTION.
DEMOCRATS ARE WATCHING
CAREFULLY, THEY KNOW THIS, THEY
CAN SMELL SOMETHING HAS CHANGED
AND THEY KNOW WHY.
NORMAL PEOPLE HATE THE VIOLENCE
THEY HAVE UNLEASHED.
THAT IS WHY THIS WEEK FINALLY,
AFTER MONTHS, JOE BIDEN GENTLY
SCOLDED THE RIOTERS.
IT IS TOO LATE FOR THAT, THIS IS
GOING ON FOR TOO LONG.
THE VOTERS NO LONGER LISTEN TO
HIM.
LAST NIGHT AT THE PRESIDENT
SPOKE A GROUP OF BIDEN VOTERS
GATHERED OUTSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
TO THREATEN AND INTIMIDATE
ANYONE WHO SUPPORT DONALD TRUMP.
THEY WAITED TO AMBUSH ATTENDEES.
THE MAYOR OF WASHINGTON CALLED
MURIEL BOWSER MADE ALL OF THIS
POSSIBLE.
SHE’S BEEN ON THE MOB SIDE SINCE
THE FIRST DAY.
SHE ALLOWED THE MOB TO HARASS
AND TERRIFY ELDERLY TAXPAYERS AS
THEY WALKED ON CITY STREETS THEY
PAY FOR.
WATCH THIS.
THE THAT COPS DIDN’T PROTECT
THESE PEOPLE.
MURIEL BOWSER WILL WITH THEM
PROTECT THESE PEOPLE.
SHE WON’T LET THEM DO THEIR
JOBS.
LAW ENFORCEMENT IN WASHINGTON,
DC IS IN SO MANY PLACES
CONTROLLED BY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
POLITICIZED JUST AS IT IS IN THE
THIRD WORLD.
IF YOU DON’T VOTE THE RIGHT WAY,
IF YOU DON’T VOTE FOR THEM, YOU
DON’T GET POLICE PROTECTION.
THE MOB IS ALLOWED TO HURT YOU.
LAST NIGHT THINGS FELL OUTSIDE
SO QUICKLY OUTSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE THAT RAND PAUL AND HIS
WIFE KELLY INTO THEIR FRIENDS
WERE TOLD TO GET ON A BUS AND
LEAVE THE IMMEDIATE AREA.
THIS INTERPLAY INSTIGATES AND WE
WERE BACK TO HIS HOTEL PAIRED
THE STREETS ARE BLOCKED AND NO
ONE WOULD LET THEM THROUGH.
THAT’S WHEN RAND PAUL WAS
ATTACKED ALONG WITH THE OFFICERS
PROTECTING HIM.
COULD GET THESE PEOPLE ARE NOT
ONLY VIOLENCE, THEY’RE
INCREDIBLY STUPID.
THEIR MOUTH FREEZERS, THERE ARE
MORONS, THEY HAD NOTHING.
SAY HER NAME THEY SCHADE SHOUTED
AT RAND PAUL PAIRED THEY WERE
TALKING ABOUT BREONNA  TAYLOR HE
WAS KILLED IN A NON- NOC POLICE
RAID. PRAYED AS IT HAPPENS, RAND
PAUL THAT BILL WAS LITERALLY
CALLED THE JUSTICE B FORREOONA
TAYLOR ACT.
HE HAS HAD TO FACE POLITICAL
VIOLENCE BEFORE IN 2017 HE WAS
NEARLY MURDERED BY A BERNIE
SANDERS SUPPORTER PAID HE WAS
ATTACKED BY HIS NEIGHBOR
APPARENTLY FOR POLITICAL REASONS
AND HAD TO HAVE PART OF HIS WILL
AND REMOVED.
IT TOOK MONTHS TO GET BETTER.
WE WILL TALK TO HIM IN A MINUTE
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED LAST NIGHT
THAT HE WAS NOT THE ONLY ONE
ATTACKS.
EVERY HAND CARRYING FOX NEWS
STAFF, NONPOLITICAL PEOPLE, WAS
BLOCKED AND BOARDED IN THE
MIDDLE OF A CITY STREET.
WATCH.
WE WANT TO BE CLEAR, WE DON’T
THINK THE VAN WAS TARGETED
BECAUSE FOX NEWS EMPLOYEES WERE
INSIDE.
IT SEEMS LIKE THE BIDEN VOTERS
POUNDING ON IT HAD NO IDEA WHO
WAS WRITING IN IT.
THEY DIDN’T CARE.
THEIR ASSUMPTION SEEMED TO BE
EVERYONE IN A MOTOR VEHICLE WAS
AN AGENT OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
THEY CERTAINLY THINK THAT IF
ANYONE IN UNIFORM PRAYED WATCH
AS BLM UNIT TAKES ATTACK OF COP
IN WASHINGTON THIS MORNING.
>> THIS ISN’T HAPPENING BY
ACCIDENT.
IT DIDN’T HAPPEN FIVE YEARS AGO.
IT’S HAPPENING NOW NOT BECAUSE
POLICE ARE MORE BRUTAL OR MORE
UNARMED AFRICAN-AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE BEING KILLED BY THE POLICE.
IT’S A HOAX.
IT’S HAPPENING BECAUSE THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY ARE ENCOURAGING IT AND
HAVE BEEN FOR QUITE SOME TIME.
HERE IS MASSACHUSETTS
CONGRESSWOMAN OPENLY CALLING FOR
VIOLENCE IN THE STREETS EARLIER
THIS MONTH.
>> HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE.
MAKE THE PHONE CALLS, SO SEND
THE E-MAILS, SHOW UP THERE
THEY’RE NEEDS TO BE UNREST IN
THE STREETS FOR AS LONG AS THERE
IS UNREST IN OUR LIVES.
THERE IS PLENTY TO GO AROUND
BARRETT GET THERE NEEDS TO BE
UNREST IN THE STREETS WE HAVE
BEEN WATCHING WHAT UNREST IN THE
STREETS LOOKS LIKE.
SHE SAYS WE NEED MORE.
SO THERE IS MORE.
PRESLEY, LIKE NANCY PELOSI AND
BROCK AND MICHELLE OBAMA AND SO
MANY LEADERS IN THAT PARTY IS
RACIAL ARSONIST.
SHE WANTS AMERICA TO DESPISE AND
FEAR EACH OTHER.
SHE IS PLEASED WHEN THINGS BURN.
PRESLEY HAS NO SKILLS, SHE NEVER
CREATED ANYTHING IN HER LIFE,
SHE HAS BUILT NOTHING.
TEARING THINGS DOWN IS THE ONLY
WAY THAT SHE AND PEOPLE LIKE HER
BECOME POWERFUL.
SO THEY PUSH HATE AND CHAOS.
REPUBLICANS FOR ALL THEIR MANY
AND VERY OBVIOUS FAULTS
AND VERY OBVIOUS FAULTS DON’T DO
THIS.
THEY DON’T DO ANYTHING LIKE
WHEN WAS THE LAST TIME A MOB OF
TRUMP VOTERS TORCHED A WENDY’S
OR LOOTED A TARGET?
AND IF YOU DID, IF YOU WATCH
THEM DO THAT, HOW WOULD YOU FEEL
ABOUT IT YOU WOULD BE REPULSED
VERY DO YOU THINK REPUBLICAN
LEADERS WOULD DEFEND TRUMP
VOTERS IF THEY DID THAT.
YOU THINK THEY WOULD ENCOURAGE
THEM TO DO IT AGAIN?
THAT’S A RHETORICAL QUESTION.
YOU KNOW THE ANSWER BE RIGHT
IT’S OBVIOUS PRAYED ONLY BIDEN
VOTERS DO THIS.
THE LEFT DOES THIS AND THEY’VE
DONE IT FOR A LONG TIME.
YEAR AGO THIS MONTH THEY
GATHERED OUTSIDE MITCH
McCONNELL’S HOME WHERE HIS
FAMILY LIVES.
DEAR MEMBER WHAT THIS WAS ABOUT?
WATCH.
>> HE THINKS HE’S ABOUT TO GET
SOME REST.
NOT IF THE CHILDREN THAT YOUR
KIDNAPPING CAN’T GET ANY REST.
NOT IF FAMILIES GETTING MURDERED
CAN’T GET ANY REST.
HE IS IN THERE NURSING HIS
LITTLE BROKEN ARM HE SHOULD’VE
BROKEN HIS RAGGEDY RINGGOLD NET.
TO STAB HIM IN THE HEART.
>> JUST ADD HIM IN THE HARTFORD
THEY MOCK THE 77 -YEAR-OLD WHO
IS RECOVERING FROM SURGERY.
THEY SAID THAT OUT LOUD.
IT WAS ON TAPE PRAYED WE
PROBABLY PLAYED IT AT THE TIME.
THE REST OF US SHOULD HAVE
STOPPED WHAT WE WERE DOING THAT
DAY AND DEMANDED, DEMAND FROM
LAW ENFORCEMENT, DEMANDED FROM
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS, AN END TO
THE THREATS, TO THE LUNATIC
BEHAVIOR AND THE IMPLIED
VIOLENCE.
IN IT THAT HAS A PLACE IN A
CIVILIZED COUNTRY.
BUT WE DIDN’T DO THAT, WE LET IT
PASS, WE IGNORED IT OVER TIME.
SO THAT THREATS CONTINUED AND